was weiß man mittlerweile übersee ist
eine 26-jährige aus den usa
sie arbeitet in der edelweiß lodz das
ist eine art hotel die den
amerikanischen truppen hier
angeschlossen ist und nur für amerikaner
und ehrengäste auch zugänglich ist sie
war im urlaub in griechenland
man weiß nicht ob sie sich dort auf dem
heimweg oder erst hier in garmisch
angesteckt hat sie kamen ende august
zurück spürte dann halsschmerzen ist am
8 september zu dieser corona teststation
gegangen mit den symptomen
man sagte ihr bis ein testergebnis
vorliegt soll sie bitte sich isolieren
soll zu hause bleiben daran hat sie sich
nicht gehalten noch am gleichen abend
ist sie unter anderem hier in den club
peaches gegangen und wir können einfach
mal gucken sie ist dann weiter durch das
nachtleben von garmisch gezogen durch
diesen wunderbaren idyllischen ort und
hat dann einfach ja eine unbegrenzte
unbekannte zahl an möglichen opfern auch
getroffen allein übers wochenende gab es
hier acht neuinfektionen gemeldet worden
ein weiterer mitarbeiter der edelweiss
lodge 24 mitarbeiter sind dort schon
getestet positiv getestet worden und auf
diese amerikanerin zurückzuführen und
sechs weitere kamen am wochenende dazu
dass offenbar waren also gäste dieser
pubs die in irgendeiner form auf die
amerikanerin getroffen sind
wir wissen auch dass sie wohl mit trump
in gewisser weise sympathisiert hatten
der vergangenheit also jemand der masken
bisher lange abgelehnt hat der den
crooner virus auch ein bisschen
verharmlost hat
wir wissen allerdings im moment noch
nicht ob sie tatsächlich so drakonisch
bestraft werden kann wie das der
bayerische innenminister gefordert hat
es stehen ja bei verstößen gegen diese
auflagen 2000 euro bußgeld im raum
allerdings wenn sie angehörige der
amerikanischen truppen ist gilt für sie
möglicherweise der nato-truppen stadt
tut und dann wäre sie sozusagen immun
gegen eine strafverfolgung in
deutschland
vielen dank jörg völkerling live aus
garmisch partenkirchen dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren